all right let's talk about comma ai
what's the mission of the company let's
like look at the biggest picture
oh i have an exact statement solve
self-driving cars
while delivering shippable
intermediaries so
long-term vision is have fully
autonomous vehicles
and make sure you're making money along
the way i think that doesn't really
speak to money but i can talk i can talk
about what
solve self-driving cars means solve
self-driving cars of course means
um you're not building a new car you're
building a person replacement
uh that person can sit in the driver's
seat and drive you anywhere a person can
drive
with a human or better level of safety
speed quality comfort
and what's the second part of that
delivering shippable intermediaries
um is well it's a way to fund the
company that's true but it's also a way
to keep us honest
uh if you don't have that it is very
easy
with this technology to think you're
making progress when you're not
i've heard it best described on hacker
news as
you can set any arbitrary milestone
meet that milestone and still be
infinitely far away from solving
self-driving cars
so it's hard to have like real deadlines
when you're like
cruz or waymo
when uh you don't have uh revenue
is that i mean is revenue essentially
the thing we're talking about here
revenue is is
capitalism is based around consent
capitalism the way that you get revenue
as a
real capitalism commas in the real
capital is in camp there's definitely
scams out there but
real capitalism is based around consent
it's based around this idea that like if
we're getting revenue
it's because we're providing at least
that much value another person when
someone buys
a thousand dollar comma two from us
we're providing them at least a thousand
dollars a value where they wouldn't buy
it
you